yeah okay Auntie's doing a good job over
there the Taylor home is a full house
three generations Under One Roof me and
my husband and then my two daughters and
then I have a two granddaughters all
right and so we're all living together
here it's definitely pretty crazy it's a
lot of people in the house so it is a
lot of fun living arrangements that
combine grandparents parents children
and others are the fastest growing
household Trend across Canada according
to the latest census nearly 1 million
households in 2021 had multiple
generations of a family two or more
families or a family living with
additional people that is an increase of
45 percent in the past two decades
multi-gen living is most common among
indigenous and newcomer families new
this year the federal government is
offering a renovation tax credit for
multi-generational households they can
claim up to seventy five hundred dollars
worth towards the creation of a
secondary unit within an existing home
this can be used for a senior or someone
living with a disability and it's a nod
to this growing trend
the Vanier Institute of the family says
the soaring cost of living and an
unaffordable housing market feed into
these types of living arrangements as
housing is becoming more and more
expensive people are looking for ways to
economize and sometimes that means
bringing more people into the household
for the Taylor household multi-gen
living makes sense as a way to pool
resources and maintain close family ties
and I have a young baby right now so I'm
quite happy that
um there are a lot of people around her
you know she'll grow up getting to know
my parents and she'll also grow up
getting to know her cousin as well as my
sister it's a little different from my
life in the Philippines but
uh I like it because I learned a lot of
new things and gaviola Global News
Toronto